Global Manufacturing is poised for a
rebound after a rough start to 2020
here's a way to see that on paper it's a
global manufacturing Purchasing Managers
Index or PMI for short the chart tracks
expected expansion or contraction and
manufacturing activity around the world
the numbers released in July 2020 so a
manufacturing sector on the mend the
score of 47.8 suggests the economy is
contracting at a slower pace than it was
earlier this spring economists rely on
p.m. eyes to get an early read on where
the economy could be headed but some
warn that these numbers can't capture
the full picture of this recession and
its unique burden on smaller businesses
the first thing to know about p.m. eyes
is where the data comes from the numbers
on this chart come from a survey of more
than 12,000 purchasing managers around
the world purchasing manager is the
person in an organization that's
responsible for getting in all the
things that the company needs to to make
what it sells they kind of have a view
on how much hiring is going on and all
the services that they might buy in from
from other companies these purchasing
managers answer questions about things
like changes in production new orders
and change in prices over the previous
month the managers report whether these
numbers were higher the same or lower
higher receives a 1 the same receives at
0.5 and lower receives a zero the
answers are then added up weight and
averaging into a score and the scores
are plotted into a chart like this one
where the 50 line marks the middle
between growth and contraction one
benefit of PMIs
during periods of rapid economic change
like the one we're in now is that
they're able to come up with numbers
fast faster than many government
measures when you're trying to measure
something as complex as an economy
you've got a trade-off and the trade-off
is between speed and accuracy or
comprehensiveness if you want to know
accurately how quickly the economy is
growing through official figures you
have to wait a few months with the PM
eyes you're getting it more or less as
it happens that timeliness has helped
PMI scheme economists a first look at
economic downturns at least they did
when the economy was behaving normally
consider what happened in 2008 during
the financial crisis that sparked the
Great Recession that year PMI is like
the flash eurozone index crossed the 50
line in November an early warning of a
coming economic contraction but official
GDP data didn't pick up on what was
happening until about three months later
and when it did it matched the trend
captured by the PMI this episode
solidified the reputation of p.m. eyes
as timely incredible tools so much so
that central banks around the world now
use the indicator to inform monetary
policies like changes and interest rates
but the economic contraction that began
in 2020 may reveal a blind spot in PMI
surveys they can't fully account for the
smallest businesses like dig workers or
freelancers that's because larger firms
are more likely to respond to the
surveys one thing that I think is fair
to say they miss out on is the very very
small businesses the modern pop stores
the restaurants the kinds of businesses
that are probably most affected by the
kind of lockdown that we've seen one of
the issues I think that surveys like
this have is that they are time
consuming so I think the information
requirement may be been tough for very
small businesses to be able to handle
doing this reporting takes additional
labor that some small businesses just
can't supply this spring companies with
fewer than 500 employees lost about
eighteen point four percent of the
pre-crisis workforce we're bigger firms
lost sixteen point six percent according
to ADP so you have to remember the
limitations that the PMI has what it is
useful for figuring out is broadly how
strong or weak the economy is growing
but it's not going to tell
you know which bits are growing which
bits are contracting another limitation
of a global PMI is that it's a composite
you have to look at breakdowns to spot
regional differences for example much of
the recent upturn can be attributed to
recent activity in China the country is
reopening for business as others in the
West are still working to contain the
virus the global manufacturing index is
very heavily influenced by China which
is the largest manufacturer on the
planet now the key thing about China is
obviously that it locked down earlier
because the pandemic hit earlier so what
it is is a sort of mix of China
recovering and everyone else going
through the contraction that China went
through in January February and March so
in a way it's sort of not telling you
about the worst of this so in this
period particularly the lockdown period
data doesn't mean what it usually does
it's not a solid still as the recovery
continues investors and economists will
have their eye on the 50 line
you